climate change crazies have figured out
how to save Mother Earth
a New York Times guest essay argues
quote short people like Greg and Dana
and kind of like me but I used to be
taller are better for the planet arguing
quote there has never been a better time
to be short you see those of smaller
stature are inherent conservationists
who save Resources by consuming less and
are best suited for long-term survival
but wait it gets better quote when you
mate with shorter people you're
potentially saving the planet by
shrinking the needs of subsequent
Generations lowering the height minimum
for prospective Partners on your dating
profile is a step toward a Greener
planet
but the global warming hysteria doesn't
end there 60 Minutes is promoting a
failed doomsday biologist
the population bomb came out you were
described as an alarmist I was alarmed I
am still alarmed all of my colleagues
are alarmed the rate of Extinction is
extraordinarily high now and getting
higher all the time
Jesse I'll start with you do you feel
guilty
yes I do I do it keeps me up at night
judge you know the shorts have been
winning they're on a little bit of a
roll finally in human civilization
they've started making a little bit of
money and now they're getting pity sex
from Green chicks
talk about how this just started
the shorts have not done well uh because
usually you have to be strong and Tall
to prosper in the world but then we
started to modernize and you can now
make money through your brain so now
people are making money in the shorts
with brain power and they're getting
more attractive women because dumb
people are irrelevant they're wealthier
all right but then all of a sudden
then all of a sudden these girls are
going to start breeding with the shorts
before you do that let me just give you
some examples of how that can go wrong
Lenin 5'5 Napoleon 5'4 Manson five two
Carter five nine and a half Kim Jong-il
five three Bezos five seven fauci five
seven mini Madoff five nine and Nadler
five three so before you start sleeping
with the shorts just realize you left
off Hitler this could happen Okay but
wait a minute I want to talk to the
so-called shorts Dana how do you explain
this well I think that the New York
Times is ridiculous remember this is a
company that ran the New York Times
editorial uh editor out of a job yes
Michael Bennett's brother Senator
Michael Bennett's brother James Bennett
because he dared to allow Senator Tom
Cotton to have an op-ed in the New York
Times that is valuable coveted
journalism space and the New York Times
Falls for it every time and does
something like this but I clicked
because I was curious yeah I want to
know about it and I just told the story
earlier this morning but I'll tell it
again for the viewers at home and on our
trip we were at a very nice hotel and
the bathroom had a motion light right so
when you walk in it's supposed to well I
it couldn't detect me
so whenever I walked in I had to like
wave my arm around
but it would turn off every 30 seconds
so every 30 seconds I had to like lean
my arm out of the shower and like no I'm
still here I'm still here so you know
it's not all that great for the shorts
yet okay Greg did you marry a tall
person or a short person oh but
everybody's tall so yeah yeah
like because here's the deal what drives
me crazy about this is that you have a
diabolical dishonest media counting on
the fact that everybody under 50 hasn't
heard of Paul Ehrlich and what a sham he
was and how he turned out to be wrong on
every one of his predictions this is the
guy who said the world was going to end
I don't know 30 40 years ago the fact
that they were able to dig him up was a
Testament of the fact they want that
idea back it's very it's very anti-human
and and it's going to be wrong as it
always is now to this High thing which
is really interesting to me it's
actually not about height at all it's
about size but you can't say that but
you're just no no think about think
about it it's not about height it's
about size it's about how much you weigh
and if somebody at the New York Times
wrote and said that being skinny was
better for the planet rather than being
fat that person would lose their job but
if he did it this way and said oh it's
short people rather than tall people you
kind of eliminate you well you obviously
eliminate that you eliminate the weight
component of it and you get away with it
I think this was done in tongue-in-cheek
but it was cowardly because you should
have said look fat people use more
resources than thin people now I'll get
my things and go because I've been fired
because that's what would happen you
know Jessica you were someone who is
very concerned about the environment did
you marry a shorter man to save the
environment I did not I married a man
substantially taller than me um which is
hard to find at least in the down the
hall where I found him
um so I I think that's interesting about
the size thing because we don't talk
about comorbidities right when people
pass away
um and the impact of you know having
diabetes and weight and stuff like that
um I think short and tall people are
great I am very happy to be a talk
you're like Harold wow Harold yeah
I'm happier that I'm like this oh all
right hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else